the prophet Muhammad s. wasallam told us
whoever builds a mosque for Allah Allah
will build for him a similar house in
jenah and we know the great reward that
will not only be gained but rather will
fill your grave after your death
whenever someone prays there whenever
someone gives Shada in the Masid
whenever someone learns something in the
Masid yes that will be something that
you will have on your
scale
how are you guys doing recently science
journalist and retired zoologist Richard
Dawkins has made an attempt to become
relevant again in the last moments of
his life by speaking about Islam let's
take a look at the video and come back
and respond in kind the way women I mean
Christianity is not great about that
it's had its problems with female vica
and female Bishops and things but
there's an active hostility to women
which is promoted I think by the holy
books of Islam I'm not talking about
individual Muslims who of course are
quite quite different but the but the
doctrines of Islam the Hadith and the
and the Quran it's fundamentally um
hostile to women hostile to gays um and
uh I find that I like to live in a
culturally Christian country country
although I do not believe a single word
of the Christian faith let's really
assess what this man is saying because
he's made a few assertions hasn't he and
this is typical of Richard Dawkins to
make assertions and not back them with
evidence he mentioned the Quran he
mentioned the Sunnah he mentioned the
Hadith however he didn't actually
provide any evidence of what he is
saying now we all know Islam has a
diametrically opposed in many ways view
on say homosexuality the morality
thereof than let's say liberal uh
societies and so on that's something
which is taken for granted we all know
that we also know that there is some
level of if you like a managerial
hierarchy in the family setting and
otherwise between men and women in Islam
but to go further than this and to say
that Islam is hostile towards women
hostile towards gays and then to compare
it with Christianity were actually the
same kind of criticism from a liberal
Paradigm can be made about Christianity
in its literal and Orthodox formats both
Catholicism and protestantism and
Judaism in fact regarding the two very
issues that he mentioned from a liberal
and feministic Paradigm so one can say
that on a liberal atheist secular
analysis for example the verse in
Timothy which talks about the man being
the head of the
household or or that man shall not not
lie with other man and the destruction
of Sodom gomorah those are things that
you'll find in the Bible so to compare
Islam and Christianity and then to use
those liberal talking points as they are
liberal talking points with small L
against them is actually a weak argument
to say the least and Richard Dawkins is
a coward because he has not been able to
argue his position as a zoologist
because that's what he is I mean why is
a zoologist talking about religion
anyway why is he talking about theology
why is he talking about philosophy why
is he talking about those things in the
first place but let's say he does want
to engage in those discussions instead
of being brave and gallant and having uh
the intellectual courage of standing
forth in front of someone who could
oppose his views and challenge them he
just makes a few sneaky remarks on the
radio well as I say we'll see what
happens when you die because that moment
is coming soon we could all die soon I
could die you could die but you're more
likely to die much quicker than I
because of your age and so you should be
thinking about really what's going to
happen after your death but one thing I
will say is this in one of your books
the blind watch maker Richard you
mentioned that there is no such thing as
morality there is no such thing as good
or evil there is only pitless
indifference so really and truly if you
read The God Delusion which is your
seminal work which is interesting
because why is a zoologist writing a
seminal work on issues nothing to do
with theology or science and when you
spoke to Dennis Noble who is seen as one
of the
esteem esteemed biologists in the United
Kingdom in fact in the world and he
rubbished your ideas and criticized you
and put you in your spot and humiliated
you
intellectually and he in fact is the one
who invented this label science
journalist viav you and your efforts you
really couldn't withstand that kind of
criticism but if you read your book The
God Delusion most of it is actually
attacks B are based on morality but if
you do not believe in an object of
morality and that everything is pitless
and difference so whether one is hostile
to gays one is hostile to women one is
hostile to men or children or animals or
anyone else that is according to you
pitless indifference it doesn't matter
if they are uh you know hostile or not
hostile peaceful or hostile doesn't
matter finally I will say this the
entitlement your speech is quite clear
for you to speak in this way and to
think of the United Kingdom as kind of
like your garden or your backyard I
wouldn't want to see this there and I
wouldn't see that there it shows you
that you don't actually have respect for
the Democratic process she kept asking
you what if you know Britain became a
Muslim majority country so on and so
forth I mean if you cared about the
principles of democracy and so on and so
forth then you would you would actually
answer in a in a way which would be
commensurate with that you'd say well if
that's the will of the majority if this
or that which shows you that you cannot
avoid the in-group outgroup tribal
Dynamics in your
last days on this planet probably or
weeks if you're lucky months you know
maybe uh in those last moments of your
withering life you've decided to attach
yourself culturally with a religion that
you've spent a long time trying to
oppose which is Christianity which shows
a lot about you finally I will say the
debate offer has always been put on the
table to you
Richard we've always said if you really
want to speak about Islam the Muslim
Community is willing to have that
conversation and before you die maybe
you'd want to summon the testicular
fortitude although maybe that has
withered as well to do
so hey you are you you wasting your time
on social media again your brothers and
sisters in Islam net from Norway are
establishing a mid a dawa Center
establishing a Masid to convey The
Message of Islam is one of the best
Deeds a Muslim can do there's a huge
need for it in Norway you know this and
I know this so that makes the reward
even greater so give generously and
Allah will give you even
more
e